FEMALE SPEAKER: Please join
me in welcoming Deb
Perelman to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
DEB PERELMAN: Hi.
Thank you so much for having
me here today.
I'm so excited to be here.
I'm a total Google dork.
I am.
I actually read my entire life
from Google documents.
It's actually what the inside
of my brain looks like.
I have like this series of--
it sounds kind of weird.
Basically, everything that I
ever need to remember, I have
to pull up on a Google Doc.
So yes, I'm very excited
to be here.
Anyway, thank you.
And this fall, Smitten Kitchen
turned six years old.
It would be a first grader.
It would be talking back, which
seems about appropriate
for me being up here.
And I'm often asked how I got
the site started, but I tend
to drag my feet.
I know that bloggers are
supposed to like to talk about
themselves, but I hate it.
I think it's really awkward
because basically, my life
story is I like to cook.
I wrote a book.
The end.
But I suppose you'd like
to hear a little
bit more than that.
So I'm just going to tell you
just like this much more.
And then what I'd love to do is
answer questions, because I
love answering questions.
I think it's way more
interesting.
When I registered the domain
name, Smitten Kitchen, in the
summer of 2006, I actually
expected it to
be a six-month endeavor.
I imagined that was about how
long most blogs lasted.
And I didn't expect this one to
last, because I read a lot
of food blogs at the time.
There were a bunch.
I read Adam Roberts' Amateur
Gourmet and Lisa Fain's
Homesick Texan.
And what each blog I read
had in common was that
they have an angle.
They have a story they're
telling about Texan food that
you miss or teaching yourself
how to be a gourmet chef.
And I don't have an angle.
I just like to cook.
And so I didn't imagine that
the blog would last.
But I do remember what
I was looking for.
And Google actually comes into
play here, too, because I
remember very early on the
site I wanted to make a
birthday cake for a friend.
And I knew exactly what
kind of birthday
cake I wanted to make.
I wanted to make one of those
yellow, layer, buttery,
vanilla-scented, plush birthday
cakes for a friend.
And I didn't have a go-to
recipe for it.
I was somebody who liked to
cook, but I didn't have these
go-to recipes.
And I decided to Google "best
birthday cake." And 1,670,000
results appeared.
You guys don't seem remotely
surprised by this.
I guess you know that.
And I had no idea
where to start.
So I started with
the first one.
And it was OK.
It was fine.
It was good.
I mean, it probably would
have been good enough.
But I'm really picky, and
I wanted to do something
different with it.
I wanted to use buttermilk.
I had all of these ideas
for birthday cake, and
it wasn't that one.
So I got to fiddling with it.
and I ended up coming up with a
cake that I thought I wanted
people to get to first.
And I wanted to share that with
people, because as much
as I love and adore Google, I
didn't want it to be this huge
recipe roulette when you are
trying to figure out what to
make for dinner or when you want
to make birthday cake.
Most birthday cakes are made
pretty much at like, what,
11:00 PM the night before
your husband's or
kid's birthday party.
And you're just hoping to get
it right the first time.
You guys seem like really nice
people, but I don't think
you're going to apologize if the
cake is a disaster, and it
slumps on the floor at
2:00 in the morning.
So I knew what kind of recipes
I wanted to make.
But at the time, I was
an IT reporter.
Oh boy, if I haven't put you
to sleep yet, I should tell
you guys about my days
being an IT reporter.
Oh boy.
I have no idea what I was
doing as an IT reporter.
If you met some of my former
co-workers, they would be
really nice about things.
But they would be like, we
have no idea what she was
doing as an IT reporter,
either.
I had no business writing
about IT or reporting.
But nevertheless,
it was my job.
And it was one of many
iterations of my so-called
career to date.
I've also been an
art therapist.
I have been a barista.
I used to write happy
birthday on bakery
cakes in high school.
I've taught swim lessons.
I have swirled frozen custard
after college classes.
I've had a lot of weird jobs.
I wouldn't say that I've
been particularly
good at any of them.
But they're what I did.
And I think what's even more
improbable or illogical is
that I decided I wanted to start
this food site, because
as I've made clear,
I don't know a
whole lot about writing.
And my kitchen is about
the size of--
like this is probably
my entire kitchen
counter right here.
I have this tiny Manhattan
kitchen, something I'm sure a
lot of you guys are
familiar with.
And I am not a photographer.
I do not know what half the
buttons on my camera do.
I just kind of just play around
until I get what I'm
looking for or not,
close enough.
And I've never really learned
to write properly.
I never went to journalism
school or anything.
In fact, this entire talk
has been one long
run-on sentence so far.
But I wanted to start
this site.
And I remember the thing that
happened very early on, the
thing that kind of changed it
for me, was I remember very
early on I'd shared a recipe.
And someone said--
they left me a comment.
And they were like, I made
your recipe last night.
I was like, mine?
You made mine?
You had one hour of free time
after putting your kid to bed,
and groceries are expensive,
and you don't know
anything about me.
And you made this recipe?
I was completely flattered,
and very
humbled, and utterly terrified.
I realized that if people were
going to spend their time
actually making these recipes,
I better start knowing what
I'm doing quickly.
Time to start figuring it out.
So that was around the time--
after one comment, there
became more and more.
And what was happening in the
comments is that people were
asking me questions, because I
had mistakenly given them the
impression that I knew
what I was doing.
People would ask me, can
I use cake flour
instead of regular flour?
What if I only have salted
butter, not unsalted?
And what if I only have
extra large eggs?
Ina Garten only uses extra large
eggs, and you only use
large eggs.
What am I supposed to do?
So people would ask me all
of these crazy questions.
And I would scramble to get
answers, because they were
there, and I wanted to help.
And I actually feel that over
the years, answering all of
these questions have really
helped me become a better
cook, that it was the comments,
it was the readers
asking these things that I had
to figure out the answer to
that really helped.
Anyway, so I started the site
in the fall of 2006.
And in 2008, I quit
my day job.
I'm sure they were like,
see you later.
Don't let the door hit you.
But I quit my day--
and it was completely
terrifying, as I'm sure, if
any of you have experienced the
deciding that you do not
need your safety net anymore.
But I think it was actually
really good for me, because it
really gave me permission to
start working on the kind of
recipes I wanted to work on.
I had been sort of fumbling
along on this site.
But now I had this grant to
start creating the kind of
recipes I wanted to each day.
And it was really fun for me.
And I think the site
probably took off a
bit more after then.
Anyway, if you cook lunch for
your friends today, and you
make them, like, a really great
roast chicken, and a
salad, and whatever else you do,
it's going to be amazing,
because you are an
amazing cook.
And your friends are going
to go, oh my god.
This is the best roast chicken
I've ever had in my entire
life, and I love this.
And you should open a
restaurant, because this is
what people do.
They say you should
open a restaurant.
And with all due respect, I
think it's a terrible idea.
I think that opening a
restaurant because you cook
chicken well is a
really bad idea.
And a similar thing happens when
you have a food blog that
has more than two
comments a day.
People say, you should
write a cookbook.
And I said, oh absolutely not.
I think writing a cookbook
is the worst idea
in the entire world.
And I will never, ever,
ever write a cookbook.
The end.
But that kept happening.
And I kept saying no.
And that went on for about
another two or three years.
And it would've stayed
that way.
And I would not be probably
standing here today.
But what happened was-- and I'm
sure not the first person
to say this-- but
I got pregnant.
And I know it's sort of cheesy,
but becoming a parent
sort of shifted my paradigm
a little bit.
OK, it was the hormones.
I was like, my baby is never
going to know what I do when
he grows up.
I was like, he can't hold
a website in his hand.
He won't know what I did.
And he'll never know
about these meals.
And what if this website--
I get tired of doing it,
and then I don't do it.
Anyway, so very logical,
rational line of thought led
me to deciding that I was
going to write a book.
But it wasn't just
that simple.
Despite saying OK, maybe I'll
write a book, I was still a
little resistant to the idea.
I am so in love with
the web format.
I wasn't one of these people who
was just like, oh, I have
a blog, and I hope I
get a book deal.
I was like, I have a blog, and
I hope if I write a book, it
doesn't ruin the site.
Because I really feel like
I love doing the site.
I love being able to write
long introductions.
You can't really fit
those in books.
I like to be able to talk
for as long as I
want, as you can see.
I love being able to
add process photos.
Most cookbooks, they just show
you a final shot, if even one.
And it looks really pretty,
but I don't think it helps
people as much cook that recipe
as a few details from
the recipe, like what the onions
look like when you chop
them or what the frosting
texture is going
to be on the beaters.
I think those things
really help.
And I wanted the cookbook
to include that.
And I really like comments
on websites.
I didn't know how I was going to
be able to have those in a
paper book.
And I still don't, actually.
So I had this whole crazy list
of rules for the book that I
basically wrote knowing that
nobody was ever going to agree
to them, and I'd never
actually have
to write the book.
That was my great, really
professional plan.
And the first one was that
I wanted to have
these longer intros.
I wanted to have as many process
photos as possible.
Although it was going to be
called "The Smitten Kitchen
Cookbook," I didn't want
it to just have
recipes from the site.
I wanted it to be mostly new.
And the book is, in fact,
85% new recipes.
I didn't want people to buy a
book that they could just get
for free online.
It seemed kind of insulting
to ask people to do that.
And then, as if I hadn't had
a ridiculous enough list of
demands, I heard about this
thing called lay-flat binding.
You know when you're in the
kitchen, and you have a
cookbook open, and it closes
on you, I didn't
want it to do that.
I think I'm like the first
author ever that came to a
publisher and said, and here's
the kind of binding I want.
I mean, I was really trying
to get them to say no.
And it didn't work, which
is why I'm here.
The last harebrained idea I had
was that I thought, even
though I was about to have a
newborn, and I'd never written
a book before, and I have this
full-time job, which is taking
care of my website,
no big deal.
I was going to write the book
in six months, because isn't
that like a normal amount
of time to write a book?
So I was absolutely insistent
that I was going to finish it
in six months.
And I insisted that they put
it in the contract and
everything.
So that was really great.
So three years later,
the book is here.
I kind of like to call
it my second baby.
At 336 pages and 2.8 pounds,
I think she's a beaut.
And I dedicated her
to my first baby.
And now I would be happy
to answer any
questions you have--
almost any, most questions.
I will not answer the question
of when I'm going to have
another kid, because I know
my mom put you up to it.
And she's totally busted.
Oh what?
You want me to-- oh, use the mic
over there or over there--
awesome-- if you want to ask
a question or heckle me.
Heckling is fine.
I can handle it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I'm Melissa.
I love your blog so much.
I've gotten away with--
like, people think that I'm an
amazing cook, and I'm not--
DEB PERELMAN: You are
an amazing cook.
AUDIENCE: --because it's
so self-explanatory.
I guess one, with the photos,
how do you do the photos if
you don't think of yourself
as a photographer?
Because I think that's a really
rich part of the site.
And also, what was the catalyst
to sort of decide
that you wanted to make the
leap, besides just like
disenchantment with your old
job and interest in this?
DEB PERELMAN: So Melissa
asked about the photos.
And I really do consider myself
a photography hack.
I mean, there are people who
can have very serious
conversations about lighting
and scrims and aperture.
And I'm like, I'm just
like reading
those words in my head.
I don't even know what
half of them mean.
I really just kind
of fiddle around.
I like working by a window.
Natural light makes
things easy.
I use a DSLR.
And I use a 50-millimeter
lens, which is often
considered a portrait lens,
because I really like to take
sharp pictures.
I know what I want the
photos to look like.
I'm just not--
the difference, I think, is a
professional photographer
could make it happen.
And I just kind of
hope it happens.
Cross my fingers.
Maybe today will be the day
I get the shot I want.
But I mostly just take photos
as I'm working.
I keep the camera right outside
the kitchen on a shelf
one foot higher than
my son can reach.
And I just usually
just grab it.
And I've gotten in the habit
of just taking photos at
almost every step, just because
I find that if I
don't, it will be the time that
it worked out perfectly
the first time.
I'm like, d'oh.
I use auto focus.
I mean, I'm such a hack.
And you had asked about
how I knew it was
time to make the leap.
Well, I've always had
ads on my site.
I try to keep them
small and subtle.
I like people who come to the
site to know that they're more
important than the little
stuff in the sidebar.
But I've always had
ad earnings.
And basically, as the site grew,
the ad earnings grew.
And because I was, like, the
worst reporter in the world, I
had basically no salary
to speak of.
So getting the outside salary
to match the job salary was
not quite the process it would
be if you had a real job.
So for me, it was really just
about figuring out if I could
make do without my
day job salary.
And that was basically
what happened.
I mean, you guys know this, but
websites make money the
same way television shows and
magazines and newspapers do.
They just sell ads along
side the content.
So the more popular the show,
magazine, readership is, the
more money there
is to be made.
But you guys know this.
You've got Google Ads.
Hi.
Oh, hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering, what
are some of the best tips or
hints that you would have to
cooking in a small kitchen?
DEB PERELMAN: Actually, I love
that question, because I have
lived in New York
for a long time.
And I didn't cook
the whole time.
in my dorm room.
And I was not this great,
motivated, young cooker.
I think it helps to start with
something that you really
hunger, like that you're hungry
for, something specific
that you're craving
that you don't--
this is New York City.
You can get most foods
pretty well.
But there are still some where
you're like, nobody makes
tomato soup the way I like it.
Nobody makes this
wild rice pilaf.
OK, I'm probably the only one
has weird cravings for wild
rice pilaf.
Pie?
How about pie?
But to start with something that
you're not getting the
way you want, so you'll be super
motivated to deal with
all the limitations of
your tiny kitchen.
I mean tiny kitchens are
absolutely annoying.
But if you're hungry enough, and
you want that enough, and
you're excited enough
to make it, I think
you'll put up with it.
Beyond that, I think that you
should clear your counters,
get all the clutter
off of them.
Like forget the coffee maker.
You can go out and buy coffee.
You can leave on what you want,
but I actually just
clear the decks.
I don't keep anything besides
maybe some salt, like pinch
dishes, on my counter
most times.
And it really helps you feel
like, at least if you have the
space, you have enough.
And remember that at all your
favorite restaurants in the
city, they are working with
stations about this big, too.
And they put out like what,
hundreds of meals a night?
So we can probably make do.
But I think the main
thing is to just to
start with one recipe.
It doesn't have to be a Smitten
Kitchen recipe.
When I'm googling for a recipe
or looking, I gravitate
towards recipes that have
comments and reviews,
sometimes to just have one or
two outside people saying, oh
my god, I made this, and it was
wonderful, gives me the
confidence to know that
I'm not going to
totally waste my time.
And then just start
from there.
And then move onto
the next thing.
And soon, you'll have a
repertoire of things that you
make, that you can make as an
alternative to going out or
ordering in all the time.
AUDIENCE: I have another
small kitchen question.
DEB PERELMAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Where do you find the
space to store all of your
gadgets and things
for the kitchen?
That's my first question.
And then, I'm also wondering,
what are some of your favorite
restaurants in New York?
DEB PERELMAN: I store things
in my son's room.
I don't know.
Things are just everywhere
these days.
At one point, I was
really good.
Like the New York rule
is like, one thing
in, one thing out.
You get a new pan, you have
to get rid of an old pan.
Or you get a new sweater,
you have to get
rid of an old sweater.
Something fell out of balance
over the process of
me writing the book.
And I have this stack of stuff
in the living room.
It looks terrible.
But beyond that pile of
doom, I actually--
our kitchen is so small, and it
has, like, three cabinets.
And when we moved in, I realized
that I could either
keep dishes in there, or I
could keep food in there.
I knew there was no way
I could keep both.
And so what we actually did
is we got a china cabinet.
And we put it out in
the living room.
And so one day, it might
actually hold china.
Now it holds everyday glasses
and dishes and flatware.
So that's been a big help.
The other thing I'm a huge fan
of is get a pot and pan rack.
My kitchen is so tiny.
But I just have a flat one.
It's like a rail.
And it's over the window.
And just anchor it with the
heaviest, strongest--
you're like, oh I only have
200 pounds of pots.
It's OK.
Get the 500 bolt.
You're not going to
be sad about it.
Get it anchored up
really well.
And the other thing is I have
some space above my cabinets,
which would normally be a
dust and grease trap.
It probably still is.
But I have some of those
vertical plate
racks, or file folders.
And I keep a lot of my
bakeware up there.
So you don't have that stuff
cluttering up your cabinets.
So anything you can do to just
clear the space out.
After that, it's really just
about deciding if you really
need two peelers or you really
need, like, eight knives.
Maybe you don't need
a knife block.
Maybe just one knife will do.
So after that, it's just choices
and yelling sometimes,
because it is really annoying.
Wait, did you have a second
question, or is that it?
AUDIENCE: My second question
was what are some of your
favorite New York restaurants?
DEB PERELMAN: Hmm, well, on
the way over here, we were
talking about Wallse, which
is this-- probably
not terribly popular.
It's like Austrian, German.
Kurt Gutenbrunner.
He's got other places in the
city that are more exciting.
But I love going there for this
time of year, good bib
lettuce salad, pumpkin
seed oil, and the
schnitzel is fantastic.
I don't have a go-to
favorite right now.
Perla is really good in
the West Village.
I don't know.
I think like most New Yorkers,
there are places I gravitate
to in my neighborhood.
I live in the East Village.
And like I love the Red Head
for fried chicken.
But I don't have an all-over
favorite restaurant.
But I'm happy to audition one
and come back to you with a
suggestion.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I love your blog.
I make tons of your recipes.
DEB PERELMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And what I love about
it is it's arranged by
ingredient.
So when I'm like, oh, I have
a butternut squash.
What should I make?
Or I have too many pears, then
I know I can go and find
something to do with it.
But what I found is with all
of your baked good recipes,
strangely, I always have
to add more liquid.
And what I'm wondering is
what am I doing wrong?
Like what is going on that
this is happening?
DEB PERELMAN: You mean
like shortbread?
Because I mean, you should check
out the scone section
where everybody complains that
everything's too sticky.
So do you mean like crumbly
shortbread type stuff?
AUDIENCE: So the first recipe
of yours that I made--
I remember this actually--
it was the everyday raspberry
cake that I make
all the time now.
It's just like a thin
sheet cake.
And you put fruit in--
DEB PERELMAN: Oh, right.
That came out dry?
AUDIENCE: When I looked at the
batter, I was like, this is
like a cookie dough.
DEB PERELMAN: Oh, yeah it is.
So actually those
are the best.
It's actually intentionally
that way.
AUDIENCE: Really?
DEB PERELMAN: When
you're making--
have you ever made the blueberry
muffins, too?
They're so thick.
It's like a cookie dough.
So the trick is-- one of the
things that I read a lot in
the comments is that
people hate it when
fruit sinks in cakes.
And actually, the trick is
to have thicker batters.
People say that if you read one
of your mom's recipes, it
will probably tell you to
dust the fruit in flour
before it goes in.
And it helps a little bit, but
actually, it's thicker batters
that spread nicely.
And it pulls the moisture from
the fruit as it cooks.
So they're actually
intentionally--
a good, thick batter, usually
works out really nicely,
especially if there's
fruit in it.
It bakes out to be a good,
tender consistency.
AUDIENCE: I never gave
it a chance.
I just added more milk because
I was like, there's no way.
DEB PERELMAN: No, no, no.
Bake it up.
It's fine.
That's a good one.
No, it's actually like
a yellow cake.
And it has this extra moisture,
which are the juices
from the raspberries.
So it keeps the fruit
from sinking.
And it also gives it a really
nice crumb, because you have
all that fresh fruit
in there that would
add a lot of wetness.
Otherwise, it can get
a little soggy.
So actually, I like when I see
good thick cake batters that
spread nicely because they
usually work out really well
and have a nice crumb.
But was there another one?
AUDIENCE: I'm just trying
to remember--
DEB PERELMAN: I'm here
to help you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I made your rhubarb muffins
with the crumb topping.
DEB PERELMAN: Super thick, too,
especially-- and it's the
same thing.
It was the rhubarb, the
blueberry muffins, like all of
them, the plum ones
in the book.
The idea is--
actually intentionally thick.
But it gets the moisture from
the fruit as it bakes.
And the fruit shouldn't sink.
AUDIENCE: So the problem is I
just have not been having
enough faith is what
you're saying.
DEB PERELMAN: You
should trust me.
You should have faith.
Well, I mean I understand why
you wouldn't trust me not
knowing me.
But I can tell you that part
is, at least, intentional.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
many times you make a recipe
to consider it tested.
DEB PERELMAN: Oh, I haven't
tested them.
Sorry.
Yeah, I have to stop
saying that.
People aren't really laughing.
So it can really range.
If I'm starting from like-- that
raspberry cake that she
mentioned is actually an
old "Gourmet" recipe.
And it's fantastic.
I think I made that twice
because it's a good recipe.
I didn't want to change
anything.
It was just really great.
That would be something
I'd put on the site.
For the book, I was stepping
a lot further out
of my comfort zone.
And so it was often things
I'd never made
or never seen before.
I wanted--
I'm not going to ask you to buy
a book full of things that
you already know how to make.
So it could be anywhere from,
I would say a minimum of six
times to there are
things that--
I mean, the lemon bars in
there, I think I like
completely went nuts.
I think I made them,
like, 18 times.
The fig challa--
there are things where I was
really stuck on one part where
I just felt like it was this
kink that wasn't ironed out.
And so I didn't want to
publish it unless I
was 100% about it.
So it could really range.
There were recipes I couldn't
even look at for, like, six
months because I was so
tired of testing them.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I was wondering, aside from
number of tries, what's your
process of creating a recipe?
Like how do you go about-- do
you look at a recipe and start
to hack it?
Or do you just think of
something you want, and you
already know the ratio?
I'm very curious.
DEB PERELMAN: You know,
it really can depend.
It can be--
sometimes, I want to make--
OK, I got this weird idea
a couple months ago.
And I haven't been in my kitchen
that much since I
started the book tour.
So we'll get to that
in January.
But I love rye bread toast
for breakfast, and I
love English muffins.
So I was like, I want to make
rye bread English muffins.
So this is the idea
I have in my head.
The first thing I would
probably do is I would
probably google it.
And I think what I will probably
find is that nobody
has my weird taste in this,
and it doesn't exist.
So from there, I've made English
muffins a few times.
And I've also made rye bread.
So I might take a couple of
these recipes and sort of mash
them together.
I actually do type up-- like
I write a recipe, including
every detail that I could
possibly think
that will come up.
I try to get my best guess
of what I think will be a
working, functioning recipe,
print it up, stick it to my
fridge with a magnet.
I've got a cup of pens up there,
take notes as I'm going
adding adjustments or oh my god,
never make this again,
with a big scribble over it.
Let's say I do find that
somebody's made it.
I might look at the recipe and
say, is this really what I
want to make?
Is this close?
If it looks really close,
I might just
make it word for word.
And if it's exactly the same,
say hey, by the way, you
should make Peter Reinhart's
rye bread English muffins.
They're amazing.
And if I make it, and it's
quite far off from what I
wanted, that's when I'll
start tweaking.
And it goes into additional
rounds.
So it can depend.
It depends on how obscure
it is, I guess.
I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEB PERELMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if there was a
particular recipe, or a few
recipes, that were your favorite
or that you thought
were most memorable?
DEB PERELMAN: In the book
or on the site?
AUDIENCE: Overall.
DEB PERELMAN: You mean
choose a favorite?
So I tend to think of food
very seasonally.
Like the things I want to cook
in December are so different
from what I want to
cook in January.
And so--
I was like, oh, English
muffins.
That's January.
Don't ask me why.
It's just this is how
I am in my head.
When I think of a wholesome
breakfast
bun, I think of January.
And when I think of decadent
French toast, I think of
Mother's Day.
So I don't know.
That's just me.
So for right now, for this
month, I'm all about, as most
people are, holiday cooking,
heavy roasts.
I think the short ribs in the
book are so great for a good
holiday party, because they
keep really well.
Like you could make them a day
or two before a party.
There are brown butter mashed
potatoes-- no, was that with
the brown-- that has
the parsnip puree.
But you can use the brown butter
mashed potatoes from
the meatloaf.
So I definitely think a lot
more about heavier, roasty
meats this time of year.
If you're a vegetarian, I highly
recommend you do not
let the month go by before you
make mushroom bourguignon,
because it's such a great
way to get that amazing
bourguignon flavor without
having to eat beef or cook
beef for several hours with
very exacting steps.
And, of course, cookies.
You've got to bake cookies
this time of year.
I love the gooey cinnamon
squares in the book are my--
like the book was done.
And they were like, could
you stop adding recipes.
I'm like just one more.
And that was the last one
they let me sneak in.
I felt it was like, we
have to put these in.
And they're basically--
you do it in a pan.
And the bottom is a
snickerdoodle, and the top is
like a layer from gooey
butter cake.
It's a St. Louis thing.
And the top has this cinnamon
sugar that you would normally
roll the snickerdoodles in.
So it's just like butter,
vanilla, cinnamon, butter,
vanilla, cinnamon and then
in tiny squares.
So it tastes like a toasted
marshmallow on top.
OK, you guys are going
to make them, right?
OK, good.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
After you've had so many
hundreds of recipes on your
blog, how are you able to
come up with all new
recipes for your book?
And what was the time frame
like in developing those?
And then also, wasn't it a
little bit heartbreaking to
not be able to include some
of the ones off of
your blog in the book?
DEB PERELMAN: So what
was your name?
AUDIENCE: Michelle.
DEB PERELMAN: Hi, Michelle.
OK, so the first question
was how did--
so I don't know.
The ideas, they just come.
I don't know where
they come from.
I mean, I would say that if I
wake up one day, and I don't
feel like cooking anything, I
have no new ideas, it's just
time to go back and revisit an
old favorite or go out and
refill the proverbial well.
I mean, we all hit
walls sometimes.
And usually, it's just fatigue,
or you're working too
hard, or you haven't taken
enough of a break.
If I've actually cooked four
days in a row, I don't even
want to look at a kitchen.
I do not cook every day.
I cook some days.
I cook when I feel like it.
That sounds really bratty.
But especially, I mean, for non-
"dinner needs to be on
the table, and we're hungry,"
it's a creative process.
And so you have to sort
of not push too hard.
But I actually keep a very--
this is the Google Docs--
I have a very, very long list.
I have a document called
Cook This.
And it is pretty much every
recipe idea I've ever had,
usually sorted by seasons
or months or holidays.
And when I say sorted, it's
very loosely organized.
But it might just be anything
from those rye English
muffins, to a salad I didn't get
to, something that didn't
make it into the book, things
that are partially made that
might link to another document
with the full recipe in it.
It's a labyrinth.
So I just try to jot
things down.
And I use the notes function on
my phone all the time when
I'm on the road.
I'm sorry.
Your second question
was about--
AUDIENCE: What was the time
frame like for developing
everything?
You said the book took
three years.
DEB PERELMAN: I said it was
supposed to be six months, but
don't do what I did.
I missed every deadline.
I think I missed, like,
two major deadlines.
I was starting to get threats.
I wouldn't recommend it.
I'm sure that my editor has some
grey hairs because of me.
I thought I could finish
it in six months.
I had no idea what
I was doing.
Always give yourself more
time than you need.
You're not going to
be sad to have it.
This is like your baby.
You should do it properly.
And so I ended up probably
getting it in about a year an
a half late.
No big deal.
Year and a half or so.
And sorry, you asked
one more question.
And I'm not usually
this forgetful.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I just asked if
there was anything from--
like if it was hard for you to
not to be able to include
everything from your blog.
DEB PERELMAN: Sometimes
I'm like, I have
something on the site.
I'm like, oh, this is so good.
It would've been so great
for the book.
But I guess I could always
decide not this week, not next
week, but maybe at some point,
I will consider writing
another book.
And it could fit in.
Or maybe one day a best of the
site could always happen.
But I don't generally feel that
by putting things on the
web I'm losing out.
I mean, I know that for some
people, their books are the
center of their career.
There are some food
personalities the show is.
For me, it's really
that website.
And so I never feel like I'm
giving anything away for free
or missing a chance to sell it
to people or something like
that, because I feel like--
I mean, in general, anything on
the site is always going to
get more eyeballs than a book.
So I'm happy to have
things there.
But maybe one day there
will be a collection.
And I mean at the rate--
it took me three years
to write this book.
Can you imagine how
long it would take
me to get that done?
A decade.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I have two questions.
The first one is, so you
mentioned in the book you've
made some recipes six times
or, like, 18 times.
So how do you stay motivated,
after you messed something up,
to do it again?
Because I find that when I try
a recipe, and it goes wrong,
I'm just so deflated.
I'm like, ugh, now I'm just
going to order pizza, because
I don't feel like cooking
it again.
DEB PERELMAN: That is exactly
what I do, by the way.
I get totally pissy, and
I storm out of the
kitchen in a huff.
And I angry text my husband.
I'm like, this is terrible.
Hope you're picking up pizza
on the way home.
I do not handle things well.
So don't worry about it.
AUDIENCE: But yet you still make
them, like, the next week
or something?
DEB PERELMAN: Eventually.
And sometimes I don't
get back to things.
It depends on if, like if I feel
like it was centrally at
fault, or even it came out
correctly, but it tasted
terrible, back to the
drawing board.
Other times, it's just like I
need to take a break from it
and come back.
And I've done that a lot.
There are things that never made
it into the book because
I wasn't really ready to
revisit them in time.
And then, actually, a lot of
them have ended up on the site
since then.
There are some Dijon-braised
Brussels sprouts that I was
dying to put in the book.
And I made them, like, 12 times,
and they were just
never right.
And all I needed to do was just
stop working on it and
take a break and come back and
be like, right, I was doing
the sauce all wrong.
I was making this
too complicated.
And then I made them.
And it was like literally one
round before I felt like they
were ready for the site,
after 12 rounds of
pulling my hair out.
Another one is there are
strawberries and cream
biscuits on the site.
And for some reason, I intended
them for the book.
But I was like--
I don't know.
They had annoyed me.
I felt like they weren't
interesting.
And I felt that they hinged too
strongly on having really
freshly picked strawberries.
And I felt like that's kind of
an unfair thing to put in a
book that's supposed
to be year round.
I mean obviously, fresh produce
is always best.
But there's really a difference
between the
strawberries that you pick and
the strawberries that you can
buy in December.
And I didn't want most people
to be unhappy with it.
So anyway, there are a lot of
things where I don't come back
to it, or I come back
to it years later.
And that's where the list comes
in, because I can always
revisit something when I feel
like and not feel like I have
to work on that until
it's done.
AUDIENCE: So my other question
is, since you've started
blogging, has that kind
of ruined going out to
restaurants for you?
Where you go to a restaurant,
and you're like I can make
this at home.
Or I would change this, and
I would make this better.
Do you ever think that?
DEB PERELMAN: Not at
all, actually.
I still love going out, because
I just like the--
and I like to just turn off the
cooking brain and just get
to try new flavors.
I usually like picking something
very weird on the
menu that doesn't sound very
good, because why would they
have it on the menu unless--
I mean, everybody has roast
chicken and steak on the menu.
But it's when you hear, like,
turnip gratin and pasta that
you're like, wow, I bet that's
good, or they wouldn't be
trying to sell it.
So I get a lot of ideas
from going out.
OK, fine, it's kind of hard
for me to buy muffins at
coffee shops.
They're really terrible
for the most part.
And I would say in almost
all cases, you can
do better at home.
There are a few exceptions.
But I would say that breakfast
baked goods are hard to get
excited about outside
my own kitchen.
But beyond that, everything
else, I'm so happy somebody
else is cooking.
I'm like, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
As somebody who's been blogging
for a really long
time about food, do you have any
opinions on Pinterest or
how this has affected your
site or the process of
figuring out stuff at all?
DEB PERELMAN: That's such
a good question.
Pinterest hasn't actually
changed anything for me.
I think it's great.
I don't use it that
much, personally.
Like, I don't pin my recipes.
But I make them pinnable.
It hasn't really caused
any static for me.
I know there are a lot of people
in the beginning who
felt like there are certainly
some copyright issues.
Is that what you meant?
AUDIENCE: Well, there's
copyright.
And did it increase your
traffic, or do you feel like--
DEB PERELMAN: I think
it has, actually.
I mean my general feeling
with new technology--
I sound like an old fogey--
with new technologies that have
emerged since I started
blogging is I actually like to
meet people where they are.
As long as it's no real trouble
for me-- like when
everybody was gravitating
towards Facebook-- god, this
makes me sound like
an old blogger--
I set up a Facebook page.
I post a link to new
recipes there.
When a lot of people wanted to
find out about new recipes
through Twitter, I created
a Twitter feed that
just updates recipes.
AUDIENCE: Then why don't you
have a Pinterest board?
DEB PERELMAN: I do have
a Pinterest--
well, to me there's a totally
different process from--
I kind of think Pinterest is
better when it's not just site
owners pinning their
own stuff.
Somebody else usually does, so
I don't usually do that.
In terms of me personally using
Pinterest, like to use
bookmarks, I don't know.
I'm very resistant to it.
I do actually have a board.
For some reason, there's
this thing.
This is just like a personal
thing, but I feel like I would
probably just create a
collection of things that I
wanted to buy and either
couldn't afford--
I felt like it was sort of
unhealthy for me to just
collects wants and needs
and whatever.
That sounds weird.
So in general, I personally--
because I know I would just
pin like really expensive
stuff that I don't really need
to be spending my money on.
But at the same time, I love
looking at Pinterest and other
people's boards for
inspiration.
As an artsy fartsy person, I
love to follow design people
and just see what
they're finding.
But I actually think it's
been great for sites.
I mean, especially with food
blogging, visual bookmarks are
an important thing.
And I know a lot of food
bloggers have changed the way
they do their photos to have
captions on them in the photo.
But I just don't want to mess
up the photos that way.
So I haven't changed that.
I don't want to.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it sounds like you do most
of your research online.
How you feel about more
traditional, like "The Joy of
Cooking" or older books?
What's in your library?
DEB PERELMAN: I love
cookbooks.
I am on the computer, so it
tends to be like the place
that I look first.
But it depends on what
I'm looking for.
I mean, I am a huge fan of--
I believe that everybody needs
"Mastering the Art of French
Cooking" in their library.
I have Larousse.
I have "The Joy of Cooking." I
have a lot of the classics.
And then I have new books
I pick up each season.
So there are a whole
bunch of books I've
picked up this fall.
I've been spending a lot
of time in bookstores.
And so every time I go,
I pick up a new book.
I love using cookbooks.
I almost prefer cookbooks
for reading.
I feel like the recipes that
come in the kitchen with me
are usually more often from a
website or something that
jumped out at me from a book.
But for the books, I like
to read them in bed.
It's like looking at a
beautiful magazine.
I wish they weren't so heavy.
I'd read them on a plane.
So I really love cookbooks for
reading, especially because
it's more of an organized
thing.
With the web, you only get
what you ask for from it,
whatever it retrieves back
based on your request.
But with a book, you end up--
I keep thinking of this roots
book I picked up this fall.
And it's like a living in a cold
climate, as most of us
do, pretty much the only fresh
vegetables we have all winter
from green markets are
root vegetables.
And I don't really know--
I have a bunch of things I like
to do with each, but this
is, like, 200 recipes.
And its stunning.
And just each page
is this new idea.
So when you are at the market,
and all they have is turnips,
wow, here are eight recipes
that are like really
original for it.
That one I've been thumbing
through when I'm supposed to
be sleeping.
So I really love it.
And I feel like buying cookbooks
is almost like
buying beloved art books,
especially with so many of
them having so many beautiful
photos these days.
There is a place for
all of them--
well, maybe not in my apartment,
but I keep buying
them anyway.
Nobody with questions?
Yeah, ask.
AUDIENCE: So I really
like the disasters
section of your blog.
I think it's really funny that
you put up the recipes that
totally fail.
And they still have these
gorgeous pictures that look
really nice.
And I'm just curious, how many
things do you cook that you're
like, this definitely goes
in the disaster pile?
Do you do them like numerous
times and fail over and over
again before they
make it there?
Or how do you decide?
DEB PERELMAN: So yeah, in the
early days of the site, I had
this disasters category.
And I used to--
if I just made something that
was an utter flop, I was like
Martha, I can't believe
you did this to me.
This is the worst recipe ever.
And it was like that.
And I've stopped populating
it so much
for a couple of reasons.
One, people would
make it anyway.
And they'd be like,
this was terrible.
I'm like, I told you that,
but it doesn't matter.
And I felt bad that
people were having
disasters because of me.
I don't want them to associate
my site with
failures in their kitchen.
The other part is as readership
grew, I felt a lot
worse calling people
out and being mean
about terrible recipes.
I'll say it, but for me, I feel
like it's far more useful
for me these days to make the
recipe work and say, this
recipe did not work the
way it was printed.
Here are a lot of changes I
made, but not just leave
people at a dead end.
So I don't do it as much, but
there are plenty of disasters.
That does not mean that we
do not have failures.
By the time they're on
the site, I've done
something with them.
Or I'll say, I've made
this soup, and
it was utterly revolting.
It was pureed spinach water.
Like I did.
It was really gross.
Here's something that I
think is a lot better.
Here's how I changed it.
So I try to lead it
to a positive--
like a happy ending, like a
romantic comedy at the end
just so it's more useful for
people than just complaining.
So yeah, but it was sort of fun
to have a collection of
things that were just awful.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there any chef or cook
that you consider
your culinary hero?
DEB PERELMAN: Oh man.
I'm not a big chef follower.
One of my favorite restaurants
in New York City was--
before it closed-- was Tabla.
I love it.
And I loved everything Floyd
Cardoz touched, I thought it
was perfect.
And so of course, I followed
him downtown.
And I've been to North End Grill
a couple times, and it's
just as amazing because
I think it's the chef.
I mean, he is what transforms
these ingredients in a very
specific way.
So that was definitely
one of my favorites.
I love Michael Anthony.
I think he was up at
Stone Barns before.
And he's at Gramercy
Tavern now.
So there are definitely some
names that have stuck out to
me at restaurants where
I've had good meals.
And I often realize that I ate
at their other restaurant at
some point.
But I do tend to follow chef
names more than I follow
actual restaurant projects.
It means a lot more to me to
know who's cooking there.
Like I mentioned this Wallse
place, this Kurt
Gutenbrunner--
well, I mean his personality
aside, he makes a lot of the
food that I like to eat.
So I wouldn't say I have one
like David Chang level chef
worship, like some name in the
stars, though you know, who
doesn't like Momofuku?
I live in the East Village, so
it's like Chang is all around
at all times.
So I don't have one.
But there are definitely names
that jump out for me more that
mean a lot.
And of course, especially when
they've had a cookbook, like
"Sunday Suppers at Lucques"
from Suzanne Goin.
I always pronounce
her name wrong.
She's out in LA.
That cookbook is one of
my favorite cookbooks.
And so then, of course, going
to the restaurant is so much
more meaningful, knowing how she
speaks and talks, writes
recipes in a whole collection.
That was not very articulate.
But yeah, there are some.
Do you have a favorite chef?
AUDIENCE: I am a big
fan of Alton Brown.
DEB PERELMAN: Nice.
For home cooking, he is it.
He doesn't have restaurants,
right?
He's just a home cook guy.
AUDIENCE: I think so.
DEB PERELMAN: He's just got
cookbooks and grape juice.
But yeah, I agree.
He makes amazing recipes
for home cooks.
I think that he, Ina, "Cook's
Illustrated--" I mean if
you're a home cook and trying to
figure out where to start,
those are the places.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]